[Musica]
Buonasera Vi chiedo gentilmente di
chiudere gli occhi io non vi vedo quindi
mi fido Però chiudeteli fidatevi
e adesso Provate a visualizzare ciò che
vi andrò a descrivere
Sei in biblioteca perché devi studiare
per i tuoi esami universitari la stanza
in cui ti trovi è grande bella elegante
Il soffitto è alto e affrescato
per favorire lo studio video La regola
del silenzio Quindi ogni movimento è
fatto il più delicatamente possibile
appoggi il tuo primo caffè sulla
scrivania i libri il tuo concorrente ti
siedi e se presti attenzione
attorno a te comincerai a sentire le
pagine dei libri che vengono spogliate
il rumore del righello che viene cercato
nell'astuccio
la matita che scrive sul quaderno
i passi di chi entra ed esce dall'aula
le persone che parlano a bassa voce per
non disturbare un po' così piano piano
piano
ora Aprite gli occhi
qualcuno di voi si è rilassato alzi la
mano che ha provato la sensazione
piacevole
voi siete la media di 8 anni fa
studentessa in crisi che per colpa di
quei suoni rischiava ogni volta di
addormentarsi sui libri in quel periodo
avrei scoperto un acronimo di 4 lettere
che mi avrebbe cambiato la vita era un
giorno di gennaio 2014 e io stavo
studiando per il temutissimo esame di
chimico organica due per combattere la
noia dello studio da casa spesso andava
in biblioteca io presto Ho notato come i
suoni intorno a me soprattutto gli altri
studenti che parlavano a bassissima voce
mi provocassero dei brividi intensi che
partivano dalla testa passavano lungo il
collo fino alle spalle e questa
sensazione era anche
accompagnata da sonnolenza
era talmente rilassante come esperienza
che un giorno di quelli ho fatto una
ricerca su YouTube che potrà sembrare
bizzarra Ho infatti cercata la parola
sussurri
e in italiano ho trovato principalmente
video di meditazione in inglese invece
tutti i video che mi apparivano avevano
in comune nel titolo un acronimo di 4
lettere a s m r
scoprendo questi video mi si è aperto un
mondo fatto di persone che fanno una
bassa voce chiamato whispering unghie
che picchiettano su oggetti che ho
scoperto a chiamarsi tapping e tutti dei
suoni gli oggetti comuni Resi speciali
perché catturati da dei microfoni ora
una domanda che vi sta venendo in mente
è tutto molto bello Chiara però che cosa
vuol dire asmr
SMR sta per autonomous sensori Meridian
Response quindi tradotto è la sensazione
è la risposta del nostro corpo a certi
stimoli che possono essere uditivi
visivi o tattili e la risposta del
nostro corpo a questi stimoli non sono
altre questi famosi brividini che spero
abbiate sentito nella visualizzazione
iniziale
ma mi spiego meglio avete mai provato
dei brividi quando qualcuno vi tocchi i
capelli o vi fa grattini sulla schiena
vi siete mai rilassati ad ascoltare il
suono del phon
vi siete mai incantati a guardare le
televendite con il loro descrivere
delicatamente un oggetto
involontariamente produrci dei suoni No
non state impazzendo Come direbbe Luna
lovegood di Harry Potter siete sani di
mente quanto me
Questi sono i brividi che intendo e
questa sensazione prende il nome di asmr
l'smr quindi parto da una sensazione
reale che proviamo nella vita di tutti i
giorni offline E allora perché non
ricreare questa sensazione online
per farvi capire i miei contenuti devo
prima descrivervi i miei video nei miei
video io uso diversi microfoni tutti
diversi tra loro e molto sensibili uno
addirittura ha le orecchie per poter
donare allo spettatore un'esperienza
uditiva il più realistica possibile e
attraverso questi microfoni io catturò
non solo la mia voce che molto spesso è
delicata sussurrata ma anche tutti i
suoni che io trovo rilassanti come il
suono della carta e sono dell'acqua il
suono della spazzola fra i capelli
questi video quindi hanno lo scopo di
rilassare chi li guarda di farlo stare
bene ma a mio parere c'è qualcosa di più
quando crea questi video mi metto
davanti alla telecamera io non parlo
solo a bassa voce o non faccio solo
suoni ma ci metto il cuore perché il mio
obiettivo è quello di far sentire a
proprio agio chi mi segue di farlo
sentire accolto al sicuro che con me può
prendersi quel momento e rilassarsi chi
sono lì per lui per lei e per il suo
benessere
e questo è il mio scopo ultimo Quando
qualcuno mi scrive che con la mia voce
nelle orecchie si addormenta in due
minuti che con me si conseguono quel
piccolo momento a fine giornata che sono
entrata a far parte della loro
quotidianità per me è tutto vuol dire
che si fidano perché il momento in cui
siamo rilassati il momento anche qui
siamo più fragili vulnerabili
i video dismr non vengono visti solo per
addormentarsi ma possono anche aiutare
in un periodo di ansia per un
particolare evento in un periodo di
stress per un periodo duro o anche
semplicemente possono essere usati per
rendere un momento della giornata da
noioso rilassante
e come potete immaginare la community
che si forma attorno a questi video è
dolce pacata rilassata gentile
C'è sempre chi Però dopo non aver
compreso ciò che sta guardando e
sentendo al posto di cercarlo o
chiederlo gentilmente si sente in dovere
di dirti di aiutarti a farti ricoverare
perché sicuramente hai qualche rotella
fuori posto
negli anni altre persone semplicemente
pensavano fossero la moda quindi che sia
io che altri appassionati ci saremmo
stancati presto di questa cavolata
altri nella loro immensa saggezza mi
consigliavano di trovarmi un lavoro vero
e lo scontro con il mondo reale però che
fa più male gente che ride di te perché
non capisce ciò che fai che pensa che
sia ridicolo che pensa che tu sia
ridicola sguardi di scherno risatine
persone che pensano che tu sia strana
che poi negli anni è diventato più un
complimento che altro E se ci pensate
tutto questo Può risultare strano perché
va in contrapposizione con tutto ciò a
cui siamo abituati in un mondo in cui
urli più forte per farti valere Io parlo
a bassa voce
in un mondo chiassoso caotico Qui trovi
il silenzio in un mondo veloce frenetico
Qui trovi la calma in un mondo pieno di
rumore si riconosce il vero potere di un
sussurro che poi andatemi a trovare
un'altra persona a cui può piacere
sentirsi dire che mi fa addormentare
e un anno dopo averli scoperti ho
cominciato a crearli un po' per
curiosità Mi sono messa dietro alla
telecamera davanti al microfono e da lì
non ho semplicemente più smesso
nel 2019 mi sono laureata e ho dovuto
fare una scelta vado a svolgere un
lavoro conseguente alla mia formazione o
Scommetto sulla mia passione
l'avrete capito ho scommesso se la mia
passione non sapendo realmente dove mi
avrebbe portata ma ora sono molto fiera
di dire questo è il mio lavoro
e Come avrete potuto pensare Io amo
prendere ispirazione da tutto ciò che
intorno potete trovarmi in un negozio a
prendere in mano un oggetto sentire che
suono fa vicino all'orecchio e
in generale Io cerco di prestare
attenzione a tutti quei momenti che
possono essere rilassanti nella vita di
tutti i giorni e tutta questa ricerca mi
fa tornare bambina ma in modo diverso mi
fa riscoprire nuovamente il mondo sotto
un altro punto di vista o meglio di
udito
avete mai provato a fare una passeggiata
nella natura e a provare a sentire che
suono fanno le piante intorno a voi o i
vostri passi al seconda del terreno su
cui camminate
avete mai frugato nella vostra borsa e
ho notato che suono fanno le vari
oggetti all'interno
da fare caso queste piccole cose può
essere entusiasmante perché ti sembra di
riscoprire la realtà intorno a te e
potete vedermi gioire per aver trovato
un particolare fiore che fa un suono che
non mi aspettavo una carta un frutto Ma
sapete la cosa bella qual è È che ho
contagiato che mi segue e ora anche loro
hanno sviluppato questa particolare
sensibilità per cui magari appena un
pacchetto di caramelle agiscono perché
sono particolarmente piacevole
come il detto la felicità va trovata nei
piccoli suoni
e sapete qual è la mia speranza è che da
questo momento vi godiate questa nuova
sensazione di riscoprire che suono fa la
vita intorno a noi grazie